what's the um like the closest
the most scared you've ever been filming
um i'm scared i mean
i'd probably say the the incident in
ohio
when uh like there was like a helicopter
there was like six different counties
the police showed up they go swat showed
like it was like
sketchy what was the prank i was uh
wearing like a white jumpsuit with a
shovel and like covered in fake blood
like
i remember that one i was in like a
bookstore asking for like
where's the dummy where's the how to
clean up a body for dummies book
like section like acting like i'm like i
need knowledge on how to clean up a body
right
someone took it seriously called the
cops and uh yeah just got arrested and
spent like a day and a half or something
in jail
why what was i i don't understand what
were the charges like um it's a
it's like an inducing panic like a
charge
yeah i found that found out about that
one i know the charge either but uh it
was like two first degrees
they were trying to push and then they
were pushing for like six months
and and that was the mo that's what
struck a lot of this [ __ ] was that i was
i had to go back to canada because i had
to and i'm awaiting this trial for nine
months
and they don't know that like at this
point we don't know i'm getting off or
whatever's happening they're just
telling me like yeah we might be able to
get down to three months or like
whatever
like and uh shut up brad koffel a lawyer
he [ __ ] saved my ass but um
you're looking at real jail time i mean
i don't i didn't know right
i think it was the nine month just like
not knowing that i could just go to that
trial and be like oh i'm actually gonna
go sit in jail now
right and i just yeah it was
not good didn't like it